voici friedrichshafen dans le sud de
l'allemagne cette charmante bourgade
pourtant son grande renommée peut
cependant s'enorgueillir d'être un des
hauts lieux de l'histoire de
l'aéronautique
c'est en effet à freddy jason kenney le
zeppelin des années 20 aux années 30 et
pline fut le leader mondial dans les
domaines de la production et de
l'exploitation des dirigeables rigide
qui dominèrent le transport aérien à
cette époque
en se basant sur son expérience ainsi
que sur de nouvelles technologies
zeppelin se lance à nouveau dans la
construction de dirigeables à usage
commercial
la conception du nouveau dirigeable
encore à l'état de prototype s'appuie
largement sur la structure de l'ancien
est clean
mais le nouvel appareil sera bien plus
perfectionné que ses prédécesseurs il
respectera l'environnement grâce à de
nouveaux moteurs orientable et à pas
variable qui amélioreront de surcroît sa
vitesse et sa manoeuvrabilité la
structure en fibre de carbone et
alliages d'aluminium apportera plus de
sécurité
la cabine de pilotage par exemple sera
protégé d atterrissage trop violent par
un airbag conséquent de l'hélium non
inflammable sera utilisé pour le
décollage
il sera également adapté à toutes les
conditions de vol y compris les plus
extrêmes dans la seconde moitié du 20e
siècle elle les avancées de la
technologie aéronautique ont rendu les
dirigeables totalement obsolète mais les
exigences et les nécessités de notre
époque ont remis le dirigeable modernisé
au goût du jour et ce dans des rôles
très variés
en dehors du tourisme et du transport de
voyageurs le dirigeable est d'une
efficacité redoutable dans le domaine de
la surveillance silencieuse un vol
silencieux à basse altitude constitue en
effet une expérience unique en 1783 les
frères montgolfier furent les premiers à
vaincre la gravité et à s'élever dans
les airs
le rêve était enfin devenu réalité
inventeur et visionnaire de tous genres
s'engagèrent sur la trace des
montgolfier parmi ces pionniers en peut
citer blanchard le premier homme à
traverser la manche
giffa
ou encore charles
les ballons à air chaud devient très
vite populaire et sur démontré leur
utilité
pendant la guerre de sécession par
exemple les américains utilisaient des
ballons à des fins d'espionnage
alberto santos dumont que l'on voit ici
dans un des premier dirigeable non
rigide a été l'un des tout premiers à
tirer avantage du moteur à essence de
gottlieb daimler les tout nouveaux
chevaliers du ciel pouvait maintenant
gouverner et propulser leur machine en
1897 david schwarz inventa ce que l'on
peut considérer comme le premier
dirigeable rigide au monde
ils étaient faits uniquement d'aluminium
et de ce fait très en avance sur son
temps mais le vrai père de la structure
rigide fut le comte ferdinand von
zeppelin un officier de cavalerie
allemande à la retraite depuis un an
avait participé à la guerre de sécession
en tant qu'observateurs au sein de la
federal balloni campagne s'appuyant sur
cette expérience des ballons il conçu
l'idée du dirigeable rigide plusieurs
ballons ou cellules de gaz formaient un
plan de compartimentation similaire à
celui utilisé sur les bateaux pour
localiser une perte de flottabilité en
cas de dommages
la structure utilisée pour réunir ces
compartiments isolé consistait en une
série de cadres transversaux de poutres
longitudinales et de câbles de
consolidation comme ceux d'ailleurs
encore le cas aujourd'hui
le premier à pine rigide le l aide un
pris son envol le 2 juillet 1900
comme le montrent ces images un poids
coulissant suspendu fournissait une aide
au contrôle de l'assiette des milliers
de curieux avaient envahi les rives du
lac de constance
afin d'assister au premier décollage de
ce dirigeable approchant les 127 mètres
de long le comte von zeppelin en
personne était aux commandes malgré la
brièveté du vol 18 minutes seulement le
rêve de ce prix n'était enfin devenu
réalité
on faisait manoeuvrer les premiers à
pline dans des hangars flottant qui
suivait automatiquement le sens du vent
ainsi le chargement et le déchargement
pouvait toujours être réalisés vent de
face
mais ces manoeuvres réalisé au dessus de
plan d'eau était loin d'être simple on
les abandonne a donc bien vite au profit
de hangars construits sur la terre ferme
la conception de ces hangars et plus
particulièrement de leurs portes
représentaient cependant de grandes
difficultés
le problème venait de leurs proportions
gigantesques qui provoquait des
tourbillons et de puissantes rafales ses
portes coulissantes améliorèrent quelque
peu la situation
elle s'ouvrait en glissant le long du
bâtiment principal les portes
télescopique furent un progrès
supplémentaires les ingénieurs avaient
su habilement mettre au point une
technique afin de faire glisser les
portes les unes derrière les autres et
ainsi empêcher la formation de
bourrasques de vent dans les premières
années le manque de savoir faire
technique faisait que les portes ne
pouvait être recouvertes que de tissus
le comte von zeppelin su s'entourer de
collaborateurs talentueux au premier
rang desquelles une vo est clair qui en
plus d'être un skipper de dirigeables
renommée joua également un rôle de
premier plan dans le développement du
dirigeable en allemagne en nommant aussi
le docteur ludwigsbourg un ingénieur à
la base de plusieurs caractéristiques
importantes du spleen n'oublions pas le
docteur carl einstein qui prit plus tard
la nationalité américaine et qui
continue à ses travaux sur les
dirigeables aux états unis et enfin le
capitaine hunt sleiman qui pilota des
épines durant la première guerre
mondiale et fut le premier skipper du
célèbre ville d'obo en 1910 simple in
fonda la première compagnie régulière de
transport par dirigeable sous le sigle
des lags
c'est premier dirigeable conçu pour le
transport de passagers parmi lesquels le
deutschland de cheval ou encore le
victoria louise furent équipés de pont
promenade d'un restaurant et d'un
aménagement intérieur très confortable
des milliers de passagers furent ainsi
transportées sur des centaines de
milliers de kilomètres et ce sans aucune
faille dans la sécurité
le seul rival sérieux du zeppelin fut le
choc trans un dirigeable en forme de
cigare dans la structure était en bois
20 exemplaires furent rassemblés
mais dès les prémices de la première
guerre mondiale la production de
dirigeables fut standardisées sur le
modèle de simples il
tout comme les alliés l'allemagne
posséder des chasseurs et ces as du
combat aérien
mais les épines permis à l'empereur
d'ajouter une corde à son arc il
possédait en effet une grande autonomie
c'était là une arme nouvelle et
puissante basé sur le modèle commercial
si l'armée de terre allemande nuque un
usage limité des dirigeables rigide la
marine suel en tirer un meilleur parti
les alliés n'étaient pas préparés aux
attaques de simples il en effet pour la
première fois il était possible de
transporter de lourdes charges de bombes
sur des centaines de kilomètres par voie
aérienne et cela jusqu'au coeur du
territoire ennemi
les alliés dur utilisé des avions pour
lui posté à ses attaques d'imprévus mais
l'autonomie et la capacité d'emport
faisait du zeppelin une menace constante
le temps de quelques raids sur
l'angleterre les allemands mis à l'essai
un ingénieux véhicules des nuages ou
paniers à espion l'idée se révèle très
efficace à condition bien entendu que la
météo y met un peu du sien
cachés dans les nuages le spleen était
la plupart du temps à l'abri des regards
comme des attaques ce système offrez une
grande précision d'espionnage
l'observateur rendez compte de ces
découvertes du dirigeable par téléphone
en 1915 l'empereur autorisa les raids de
simples in sur des bases de l'armée et
de la marine britannique
les premiers raids de de zeppelin eu
lieu ce même mois faisant quatre morts
et 16 blessés parmi la population civile
de la côte est de l'angleterre
l'angleterre ne revit les simples inc en
avril ils opéraient dorénavant à partir
de bases situées en belgique
d'autres dirigeable comme celui à
l'écran que le revois en train de
survoler varsovie prirent pour cible la
pologne dans le cadre de la campagne
allemande contre les russes
à partir du printemps et durant l'été
1915 londres fut attaquée pour la
première fois le 30 mai les epr in fear
cette victime ce jour là
pour contrer cette offensive d'un
nouveau genre la défense s'organise à
comme elle le pouvait quelques
mitrailleuses et quelques projecteurs et
la coupure de la lumière des réverbères
mais l'efficacité de cette défense reste
à toute relative le spleen démontra
toute sa valeur tactique lors de la
bataille de jute landes en donnant par
radio à la flotte allemande des
informations sur les positions de la
flotte anglaise ce fait historique fut
d'ailleurs confirmée par un rapport
officiel britannique les épines ont
réalisé un véritable exploit en sauvant
la flotte allemande durant la bataille
du judo
dans un effort pour contrebalancer
l'effort de guerre allemand l'amirauté
britannique lança le dirigeable ss
utilisés pour repérer les sous marins
dont nous voyons ici la préparation au
décollage équipé d'un moteur rolls royce
poc de 75 chevaux
le ss pouvait atteindre une vitesse de
46 noeuds le tuyau qui sûrement délice
servette et canaliser l'air provenant de
l' enveloppe de manière à maintenir la
pression interne
envol les dirigeables britannique se
révélèrent d'une manoeuvrabilité
surprenante
les anglais utilisèrent également une
seconde sorte de dirigeables de
reconnaissance plus grand que le
précédent
le cost all-star sa nacelle et est basé
sur un fuselage d'avion à la fin de la
guerre ce type de dirigeables pouvait
rester en l'air pendant 48 heures
d'affilée
il était équipé d'une radio et de bombes
les anglais possédait également un
ballon d'observation qu'il fallait faire
décoller à l'aide d'un treuil les
soldats pouvaient ainsi surveiller
l'activité ennemis et diriger plus
efficacement l'artillerie terrestre
comme à l'accoutumée le contact avec le
sol était maintenue grâce au téléphone
mais ces ballons et leurs occupants
constitué des poids rêvée pour les
chasseurs ennemis qui les harcelaient de
balles incendiaires
c'est pourquoi les aéronautes furent
dotés de parachute un luxe qui ne fut
pourtant jamais accordé à leurs
collègues aviateurs
les dirigeables de classe ss furent
équipés par la suite de mitrailleuses et
de bombes mais l'expérience révéla
qu'ils étaient bien trop instable pour
attaquer efficacement une cible aussi
difficile à atteindre car sous marins
leur technique habituelle fils ont bien
travaillé en étroite relation avec des
navires de surface qu'il pouvait alors
efficacement dirigé droit sur leur sol
les chasseurs et la défense anti
aérienne britannique su reprendre
graduellement le dessus en mettant tout
simplement le feu à l'hydrogène contenu
dans le cercle et ce qui eut pour effet
de stopper virtuellement tous les raids
sur l'angleterre mais les applis noir et
r pas pour autant leur mission de
reconnaissance
durant les quatre années que durera le
conflit les allemands menaient à bien
plus de 300 raid et plus de 1000 mission
de reconnaissance
en chiffres cela correspond à 10% de vol
de bombardements et pas moins de 90% des
vols de reconnaissance pur
sur les 116 dirigeable rigide utilisée
durant la guerre un tiers fut perdue à
cause de défauts de conception et de
manoeuvre malheureuse
un autre tiers tomba sous le feu a lié
le dernier tiers quant à lui sorti de la
guerre sans dommage
il est surprenant d'apprendre que seuls
4 141 soldats et officiers allemands
trouvèrent la mort sur un dirigeable
en quatre années de conflit l'une des
victoires aériennes les plus mémorables
pour les alliés provins de la chute du
spleen
elle est de 37 en belgique la mort de
fun spleen datent de la même période en
mars 1917 la poursuite du rêve échu donc
à hugo clere la grande bretagne n'avait
commencé à étudier les applications
militaires du dirigeable que très tard
il ne pouvait donc essayé de copier les
créations allemande en se basant sur de
très fragmentaire informations mais la
chance était avec les alliés il réussira
à battre de ses plis de militaires sans
trop les endommager ce qui leur permet
de les étudier de la proue à la poupe
à la fin de la guerre les alliés se
partagèrent ceux qui restent à de la
flotte discipline et pour poursuivre
leurs études sur les dirigeables ainsi
des britanniques pur dès 1919 sortir le
r34 une copie du cercle satisfait du
résultat ils entreprirent immédiatement
de lui faire traverser l'atlantique
son atterrissage à lang island marque à
la première traversée transatlantique
par voie aérienne entre l'angleterre et
les états unis le 1er 33 réplique exacte
du r34 fut surtout utilisés à des phases
expérimentales il fut notamment le
premier dirigeable rigide a quitté le
sol avec un avion et à le lâcher
directement en vol l'intérêt de la
compartimentation discipline fut de
nouveau confirmé si besoin était
lorsqu'un ma d'arrimage perse à la
partie avant du à 33 sous l'effet d'un
vent violent
le dirigeable ni en effet aucun problème
à rejoindre sa base en dépit
d'impressionnants d'égal
en 1921 la marine américaine achetée à
eur38 ou zr de à la grande bretagne
il était conçu à la base pour une
utilisation à haute altitude mais des
essais apas altitude avaient cependant
été effectuée pendant la conception de
l'appareil mais faisant subir à ce
dernier des charges aérodynamiques bien
trop importante
l'hydrogène contenu dans le dirigeable
s'enflamma et les anglais décidèrent de
prendre leurs distances par rapport au
modèle c'est clean pendant ce temps aux
états unis l'amiral moffat le grand
patron de l'aéronavale militait en
faveur du dirigeable rigide son ambition
avouée était de faire des états unis la
première puissance aérienne mondiale
le premier dirigeable rigide américain
fut le zr 1 ou fernando à la structure
fut fabriqué dans les ateliers d'un
chantier de l'aéronavale à philadelphie
et l'appareil fut assemblée dans le
hangar géant de la naval air station à
la créa sept dans le new jersey
le shenandoah qui date de 1923 et est
une version modifiée du cpl 49 abattu en
france en 1916
l'importance du shenandoah ne tenait pas
tant à sa modernité mais plutôt à son
statut de premier dirigeable rigide
conçu sur le sol américain il prit son
premier envol en septembre 1923 pour un
survol rapide de l'océan
plus tard il sillonnera le pays et ce
quelles que soient les conditions météo
l'une des qualités duchesneau a vu sa
robustesse en janvier 1924 une rafales
dépassant les 120 kilomètres heure la
rachat de son mât d'arrimage sur lequel
ne perdait plus qu'un petit morceau de
sa proue il put cependant revenir sans
difficulté malgré ses deux premières
cellules de gaz hors d'état et en dépit
du tissu arraché sur la quasi-totalité
de son aileron supérieur le chaland de
doha fut par ailleurs le premier
dirigeable rigide à s'amarrer sur un mât
flottant construit par l'année
ce mât avait été installé sur le
pétrolier patocka parmi ses exploits on
peut noter un voyage de près de 15000
kilomètres autour des états unis à
l'automne 1924 avec escale au texas
à san diego en californie et fort lewis
dans l'état de washington
la shenandoah fut perdue durant un orage
le 3 septembre 1925 au dessus de l'ohio
sa chute entraînant la mort de quatorze
hommes dont le capitaine de corvette
zakkari dempster
la section avant flotat au gré du vent
pendant plus d'une heure avant
d'atterrir sans dommage
les huit hommes qu'elle abrités sous le
commandement du capitaine de corvette
rosendaël s'en sortir indemne voici la
conclusion de la commission denquête la
destruction du dirigeable est due en
grande partie à de grandes formes
aérodynamiques extérieur découlant de
vents violents arrivant à grande vitesse
l'enquète et révéla que le fait d'avoir
ôté certaines valve de sécurité pourrait
être la cause d'une pression excessive
d'hélium à même de faire céder une
partie de la structure l'accident amena
de grandes améliorations dans la
conception des dirigeables
il fallait maintenant réduire la
longueur et la finesse de la structure
par rapport à son diamètre maximal ce
qui aurait pour effet d'accroître la
solidité de l'ensemble la nacelle de
contrôle ferait dorénavant partie
intégrante de la carlingue de cette
manière elle ne pourrait en être
arrachés les moteurs seraient aussi
intégré à la carlingue
outre le gain en aérodynamisme ils
deviendraient également plus accessible
les dirigeables suivant baptisé akron et
makon intégrèrent toutes ces
modifications ainsi que quelques autres
en 1926 après son récent échec dans la
conquête du pôle nord en avion le
norvégien roald amundsen que l'on peut
voir sur ces images décida de tenter à
nouveau l'expérience mais cette fois en
dirigeable
c'est à l'américain lincoln ellsworth
qui finance à l'expédition
le dirigeable quant à lui était italien
à rincon le baptisa norgay le narguer
était plus petit que les dirigeables de
l'époque beaucoup de gens se demandaient
alors s'il serait à la hauteur de la
dangereuse tâche qu'elle et lui être
confié le skipper de l'expédition était
le colonel umberto nobile
elle soit c'est amundsen furent tous
deux du voyage l'équipage était un
mélange d'italien et de scandinave et
mussolini profita bien évidemment de
l'occasion à des fins de propagande
la langue et se dirigera tout d'abord
vers le spitzberg
le point le plus septentrional de
l'europe via l'angleterre et la russie
le vrai départ eu lieu le 11 mai 1926 le
dirigeable fut immédiatement plongé dans
un épais brouillard qui causa le gel de
plusieurs de ces parties vitales
le commandant qui passa presque tout le
vol s'endormir décida donc de l'emmener
au dessus des nuages à la lumière du
soleil
une étrange anecdote nous est parvenue
de ce voyage au moment de lâcher les
drapeaux nationaux au dessus du pôle les
membres d'équipage se seraient
chamaillés au sujet de la taille de ces
drapeaux celui de l'italie étant
largement plus grand que les autres
cette expédition fut la première à
traverser le pôle par voie aérienne
deux jours après le départ du spitzberg
le narguer atterrissez atherey alaska
pour combler une partie de sa tête de
guerre l'allemagne avait dû construire
un dirigeable pour les états unis
ce dirigeable le cder 3 arriva à lakers
le 15 octobre 1924 il fut baptisé los
angeles en janvier 1928 au large de word
island le los angeles a atterri sur le
pont d'envol du porte-avions saratoga
la manoeuvre se révéla être un franc
succès même si le dirigeable salut à son
comité d'accueil en déversant sur leur
tête ses ballasts
un mois plus tard le los angeles réalisa
la première liaison directe entre new
york et panama city
un trajet de 3600 km parcourus en un
jour et demi en 1929 il réussit à
accrocher un avion en plein vol
c'était un progrès révolutionnaires et
qui ouvrait des opportunités
extraordinaires
l'association du dirigeable et de
l'avion permettait des fonctions
qu'aucun des deux ne pouvaient jusque
alors réaliser seule la vitesse et la
manoeuvrabilité de l'avion et elle est
parfait complément de l'autonomie et de
la grande capacité de charge du
dirigeable
en 1931 le los angeles se servit du
pétrolier patocka comme base opératoire
pour une durée de trois semaines
cela prouve l indépendance du dirigeable
par rapport aux installations terrestres
il fut absent du lakers cependant au 27
jours après avoir volé plus de 22 mille
cinq cents kilomètres de los angeles
servi d'appareils écoles mais également
de laboratoire volant son usage
opérationnel reste cependant très limité
la navy ne possédant que très peu
d'hélium à cette période une phrase
célèbre à cette époque résumé très bien
la situation
la navy had de dirigeables et autant de
litres d'hélium le los angeles n'ont
effectué un important pas moins de 330
et un vol pour un total de quatre mille
trois cent vingt heures de vol mais ces
vols furent interrompus en 1932 à cause
du marasme économique qui régnait alors
aux états unis on continue à néanmoins
les expériences au sol jusqu'à son
démontage en 1939 alors qu'il était
encore tout à fait capable de veulent
à la même période en allemagne
l'industrie du dirigeable avec hugo à
kenner à sa tête ne se laissaient pas
distancer par les états unis
le légendaire graf zeppelin vite ainsi
le jour en 1928
c'était 2008
belfast samedi 15 mai dans bodycount
skies entre belle aux signaux de
commande de moteur identique à goyrans
le jeu
le graf zeppelin nouvelle z 127 fut bien
plus qu'un simple jouet pour
millionnaires désoeuvrés il allait
devenir l'une des légendes du ciel d'une
longueur de 236 m ce fut le plus grand
appareil jamais construit il pouvait
contenir quelques 84 mille mètres cubes
d'hydrogène
le magic a eu copie
il ya 17 sept
le grave aucune n'était pas caché il
incarne est aussi le summum du luxe en
matière de voyages aériens à cette
époque il comprenait des cuisines une
salle à manger ainsi que dix cabines
doubles chacune possédant son propre
hublot panoramique son premier grand
voyage fait une traversée de
l'atlantique en vue d'une tournée de
promotion aux états unis en 1928
le voyage fut ainsi turbulent pour les
passagers parmi lesquels se trouvaient
est clair rosenthal et lehman mais ils
arrivèrent sans dommages après 100
heures de vol
l'accueil qu'ils reçurent à new york sur
passe à tout ce qu'ils avaient pu
connaître auparavant mais cette épopée
ne tarda pas être éclipsé en août 1929
le fz100 27 financé par le magnat de la
presse william hurt se lança dans un
périple autour du monde
la première étape partie de lakers dans
le new-jersey est arrivé directement à
free d'échapper
et itinéraires traverser ensuite
l'europe de l'est et l'immensité du
continent asiatique
l'étape de tokyo se déroula sous les
acclamations de la foule nippone
ma grave se lance alors dans la
traversée du pacifique jusqu'à los
angeles sur la côte ouest des états unis
la dernière étape ramena le dirigeable
sur la côte est où l'équipage pu
participer à une parade organisée en son
honneur par la ville de new york
graf zeppelin furent retirés du service
en 1937 après le tristement célèbre
incendie du hindenburg mais aussi à
cause d'une pénurie d'hélium en
allemagne mais le graff avait déjà
largement prouvé la viabilité
commerciale des dirigeables rigide
les chiffres de ces neuf années de vol
parlent en sa faveur
tout ceci fut réalisé sans aucune perte
et même sans aucune blessure
les airs sont r101 britannique datant de
la fin des années 20 furent conçus en
partant de rien ils étaient censés
assurer le transport de passagers entre
les différents pays de l' empire
britannique
le r sans effectué à plusieurs essais
concluants par gros temps dont un voyage
transatlantique allers retours entre
lons les montréal au mois d'août 1930 le
r101 connu un destin plus heurter juste
après sa construction il fut décidé de
le couper en deux et de lui rajouter une
section supplémentaire afin d'améliorer
sa capacité d'emport avant d'avoir pu
être sérieusement testée en l'envoyant à
te faire une tournée de démonstration en
inde mais quelques jours avant son envol
en détecte à des signes de détérioration
et de tensions dans la toile à l'avant
de sa structure on ne sait pas si ces
informations furent sciemment dissimulé
ou s'il on a sous-estimé le problème
toujours est il que le chef du ministère
de l'air lors de thomson qui devait
faire partie du voyage n'en fut pas
informé un petit test en vol fut
effectuée et les préparations suivirent
tranquillement leurs cours
le décollage eu lieu le soir du 4
octobre 1930 le plus grand dirigeable du
monde pris son envol par un vent
conséquent et entama la première étape
de son voyage en direction de la france
les conditions météo déplorables en plus
d'un moteur déjà en panne peu de temps
après le départ eurent raison du r101
qui s'écrasa sur une colline dans la
campagne de pouvait il explosa et pris
feu immédiatement
des faits
directeur c'est vrai vie à l'abri pour
un temps
voilà
mon permis
élan et général
la masse dans la rue chef shirts isles
internationale
le chip leader
tous ces athlètes
le bâtiment 1
tiens
le prouver
que
en 1926 les états unis relancèrent leur
étude sur les dirigeables dans le cadre
d'un programme prévu pour une durée de
cinq années
ce programme incluait la construction de
deux dirigeables rigide 270 mille mètres
cubes chacun sait la goodyear zeppelin
corporation d'akron dans l'ohio qui
remporta la compétition pour ce
programme
en 1929 le gouvernement décida
d'octroyer 8 millions de dollars pour la
construction de ces deux dirigeables
le fait de construire de dirigeables en
même temps permis de réduire
considérablement les coûts d'étude et de
développement
le premier dirigeable baptisé akron
revint à 5 millions trois cent cinquante
huit mille dollars
le second le makon ne coûte a quant à
lui que 2 millions 600 mille dollars
soit presque deux fois moins ces
dirigeables inclus et plusieurs
innovations techniques de maicon et
l'akron était en effet doté de trois
quilles une grande amélioration par
rapport à l'unique qui décline les huit
ellis pouvait non seulement s'inverser
mais également pivoter à 90 degrés ainsi
l'appareil pouvait être dirigée de
toutes les manières possibles tant
horizontalement que verticalement le
poids du carburant consommé était
contrebalancée par un condensateur qui
récupère lé gaz d'échappement du moteur
pour les transformer en eau le premier
vol de la crown eu lieu en septembre
1931 la navy l'avait affublé du doux nom
de z rs4 la collaboration dirigeable
avion avait déjà été testée avec le los
angeles la crown et le mc coy
continuèrent donc sur cette lancée
chacun de ces dirigeables pouvait
accueillir cinq avions grâce à leur art
sous intégrés
les avions étaient embarqués est lâché
dans les airs grâce à un système de
trapèze cette manoeuvre de va très vite
banal mais malheureusement la crown
connu un triste sort la tête de série
est souvent vous avez laissé au hasard
c'est peut-être une saison avec le club
d'al gharafa
m
en un an et demi la crown accumulent à
74 oil et passe à 1700 heures dans les
airs
ces voyages dans menèrent sur les côtes
est et ouest des états unis ainsi qu'à
cuba et à panama
il participa également à des exercices
militaires avec la flotte américaine et
il effectua plusieurs vols expérimentaux
sa carrière prit fin tragiquement il
s'écrase à dans l'atlantique en avril
1933 presque tout l'équipage péri dans
cet accident
y compris l'amiral moffatt l'explication
la plus probable une manoeuvre malvenue
trop près de la surface qui aurait
émergé la queue de l'appareil
la solidité de la structure fut mise en
doute mais sans qu'aucune preuve ne
puisse jamais étayer ses soupçons
pourtant un dirigeable pouvait supporter
des conditions météo bien pire que celle
subie par la croix la perte de ce
dirigeable aurait cependant pu être
évité par l'application de nouvelles
avancées technologiques
en premier lieu des rapports
météorologiques plus précis ne tardèrent
pas être communiqués aux appareils qui
pouvaient ainsi contourner les zones
trop turbulents de plus à l'époque de la
crown d'altitude était calculée par le
biais d'un baromètre calibrée en pied
qui n'indiquent est pas forcément la
véritable altitude on sait par exemple
que lorsque son altimètre indiqué 1600
pieds l'akron était en fête à seulement
1280 pieds au dessus de la mer
la technique moderne utilise maintenant
des altimètres radiométriques une totale
fiabilité
d'autres instruments améliorer encore la
sécurité en vol parmi lesquels bien
entendu le radar le mc cain était encore
en construction
lorsque s'est produit l'accident de la
crown il fut mis pourtant en service en
1933 et on voyait à sunnyvale en
californie dans une base qui allait
bientôt porter le nom de moffat field
dans les 18 mois qui suivirent le makon
s'envola 54 fois il parcourut ainsi plus
de 90 mille milles nautiques en 1800
heures il pouvait lâcher récupérer ses
avions de jour comme de nuit et ce
quelles que soient les conditions météo
ce qui constitue en l'espèce un grand
progrès technique en 1934 durant un vol
en détectant un problème naissant dans
la structure de la poupe les hommes
effectuèrent un rafistolage de fortune
mais on décida de repousser les vrais
réparation jusqu'à la fin des manoeuvres
de la flotte le 12 février 1935
après une journée de manoeuvres le makon
molette en direction de sa base alors
que le dirigeable virer afin d'éviter
une bourrasque l'empennage supérieur se
brisa et déchire à deux compartiments de
gaz à l'arrière la perte d'hélium
déséquilibre a fortement l'appareil
les moteurs continuèrent tant bien que
mal à maintenir le mât cogne dessus du
plafond de pression mais l'hélium
continuait à s'échapper par les valves
de sécurité
le temps était compté la fuite d'hélium
était bien trop importante pour pouvoir
la compenser en lâchant du lest
le dirigeable s'enfoncer lentement dans
l'océan
le seul point positif fut la manière
dont l'évacuation du mas connu conduite
on ne déplore en effet que deux disparus
sur les 83 membres d'équipage
rétrospectivement la navy se rendit
compte qu'elle avait commis une erreur
de jugement en repoussant les
réparations structurelles au lieu de
régler le problème dès son apparition
mais les manoeuvres de la flotte ne
pouvait continuer sans la participation
de l'unique dirigeable amérique
aucun appareil ou navire ne peut être
vraiment efficace s'il n'en existe pas
plusieurs exemplaires cela fournit non
seulement des solutions de rechange mais
cela augmente également les possibilités
de développement bien que les états unis
n'est jamais possédé plus que 4
dirigeable rigide
cette nation prix néanmoins une part
importante quant aux avancées techniques
de ce type d'appareil
il améliorait ont notamment les
manoeuvres au sol ton pour la technique
que pour le matériel
à l'origine ces manoeuvres se faisait
uniquement par le biais d'un équipage au
sol les anglais furent les premiers à
utiliser le mât d'ancrage solution
reprise plus tard par les américains
mais cette voie n'était pas si
satisfaisante car une fois ancré le
dirigeable était difficile d'accès et
surtout il devait garder ses moteurs en
marche afin de maintenir la sustentation
même ainsi les turbulences sont
imprévisibles
ces images montrent ce qui est arrivé
aux los angeles
cet accident précipita le développement
d'un mât raccourcis de plus la roue
arrière utilisés auparavant fut remplacé
par un chariot amovible qui bloquaient
la poupe et l'empêché de se soulever le
makon n'avait repris améliorer ses
méthodes européenne il utilisait un mât
raccourcis et était rentré dans son
hangar à l'aide de voir
le fz100 29 universellement connu sous
le nom d'hindenburg entrée en service en
1936 entre le mois de mai le mois
d'octobre de cette même année il réalise
a dit voyages transatlantiques entre
francfort et les coeurs c'est ainsi que
quelques voyages en amérique du sud
le confort était de grande qualité et
cuisine cabines de luxe douche pont
promenade salle de lecture salon avec
piano à queue fumoir est bas si l'on
ajoute à tout cela l'absence de bruit et
de vibration lunenburg été véritablement
le parangon des dirigeables transat
hante
en plus des passagers et du courrier les
netbooks transporter des marchandises
diverses et variées comme par exemple
des canaris des automobiles ou encore
des avions entre mars et décembre 1936
linenberg parcouru plus de 320 milles
kilomètres en accueillant trois mille
passagers et 20 tonnes de courrier et de
fret
il a assuré tous ses vols et n'a jamais
fait demi tour
les allemands avaient démontré là que le
dirigeable rigide était un moyen de
transport sûr et très confortable il
était bien plus rapide que le paquebot
il respectait ses horaires et ses prix
rester dans la limite du raisonnable
mais le plus important était la sécurité
offerte par le dirigeable
mais quelles étaient les raisons de la
réussite des allemands
comparé aux difficultés rencontrées par
les dirigeables anglais américains
d'expérience et la continuité sans les
réponses les plus évidents sur 157
dirigeable qui ont vu le jour
138 ch rassemblés par des firmes
allemandes l'angleterre en construisit
16 et les états unis 3
et pourtant ce fut l'accident de
l'engelbourg qui marqua les esprits et
qui devint à tout jamais le plus grand
désastre de l'histoire du dirigeant
avoir étrillé très classique
baroin
les gars
en france trois marins français
cette prime
beaucoup de théories ont été avancées
quant aux causes de cet accident est
claire a d'abord cru à la thèse du
sabotage
aujourd'hui deux nouvelles études
scientifiques donnent à penser que ce
n'est pas tant l'hydrogène qui fut en
cause mais plutôt le procédé de
durcissement de l'emploi l'âge utilisé
sur la structure externe est clair bâti
encore un dernier simple in mais qui fut
bien vite démantelé au profit d'avion
pour la luftwaffe à l'entrée de la
seconde guerre mondiale
le dirigeable rigide et est quasiment
devenu obsolète néanmoins les allemands
comme les alliés utilisèrent les
dirigeables non rigide de diverses
manières
ces images proviennent de la campagne
africaine des nazis un observateur
prenez place dans une nacelle attaché à
un câble
il signalait ainsi les positions
ennemies aussitôt transmise aux unités
d'artillerie
en angleterre on s'est servi des ballons
comme barrage aérien postés à des
endroits stratégiques ils servaient de
boucliers contre les avions ennemis qui
york et les câbles en acier reliant les
ballons au sol
la navy américaine utilise a aussi des
balans d'observation sur ces navires de
guerre les américains les utilisèrent
notamment apple arborent ces
observateurs volant accompagné par
ailleurs fréquemment les escortes de
convois sur l'atlantique afin de repérer
les navires ou sous-marins ennemis
les etats unis se servir également de
ballon pendant la campagne du pacifique
on en compte à approximativement 160
dans les rangs de la navy pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale
ils reprirent du service durant la
guerre de corée ce qui relance à leur
production
mais ils ne tardèrent pas à être
dépassés techniquement et de fêtes
furent de moins en moins utilisé mais
les ballons d'observation pouvait encore
jouer un rôle de défense important voici
le dernier ballon construit par goodyear
pour les besoins de la navy le zpg 3w
d'une taille bien plus importante que
celle de ses prédécesseurs
il devait convoyer du matériel pour le
tout nouveau réseau de défense américain
il remplit cette fonction jusqu'en 1962
depuis cette période goodyear continue
de produire des dirigeables en petit
nombre toutefois sur leur site de win
for blake près d'akron dans l'ohio
on peut voir à l'image de modèle à ses
anciens le mayflower et la colombia
ils remplissent diverses fonctions sur
tout le territoire des etats unis
outre le rôle de support publicitaire
les dirigeables accueille des caméras
filmant des sports aussi variés que le
football américain ou même les régates
voir le golf ou même les 500 miles d
indianapolis
les spectateurs ont pris l'habitude de
voir les dirigeables goodyear survolé
les stades
encore aujourd'hui il continue de tenir
ce rôle sur la plus grande partie du
club
l'instabilité leur vitesse réduite et
leur autonomie en font le support
parfait pour des équipes de tournage
ils sont aussi très utiles pour
l'observation de réserves naturelles ou
de forêt en effet leur bruit réduit
n'éveille pas l'attention des animaux
sauvages
les dirigeables peuvent également servir
en cas de gros incendies
le survol de sites archéologiques ou
historique fait aussi partie de leurs
attributions
le dirigeable servent également de
stations météorologiques volante afin
d'étudier le temps la pollution de l'air
la pression atmosphérique ou encore les
effets des vols supersoniques
de nos jours on peut estimer une grosse
vingtaine le nombre de dirigeables en
activité dans le monde la plupart
transportent des caméras de télévision
des touristes ou bien servent de
supports publicitaires mais de nouvelles
fonctions le rang récemment été
attribués
ainsi la police coréenne les a utilisés
lors des jeux olympiques de séoul en
le ministère britannique de la défense
on a d'ailleurs acheté un à titre
expérimental
les garde-côtes américains envisagent de
s'en servir pour la surveillance des
côtes de la floride
dans le cadre de la lutte contre la
drogue mais il existe un domaine dans
lequel mais dirigeable pourrait être
bien plus largement utilisé le transport
de marchandises en des points éloignés
war inaccessible par d'autres moyens de
transport
pour l'instant le cargo lifteurs n'est
encore que virtuel mais le jour n'est
pas loin où ce dirigeable de la taille
d'un cuirassé décollera d'un aérodrome
allemand
selon un terrain descendants des
appareils du comte von zeppelin long de
250 mètres pourra transporter des
turbines des containers des générateurs
ou n'importe quel autre marchandises
volumineuses et cela sur des milliers de
kilomètres capacité sera de 160 tonnes
cubique
un voyage qui prendrait normalement six
semaines ou plus par mer ou par route
sera ainsi réduit à moins de six jours
en cargo leapster il est fort possible
que nous assistions très bientôt à la
renaissance de ce vaisseau des cieux le
dirigeable